this is a video for anyone who already
knows what eigenvalues and eigenvectors
are
and who might enjoy a quick way to
compute them in the case of two by two
matrices
if you're unfamiliar with eigenvalues go
ahead and take a look at this video here
which is actually meant to introduce
them
you can skip ahead if all you want to do
is see the trick but if possible i'd
like you to rediscover it for yourself
so for that let's lay out a little
background as a quick reminder
if the effect of a linear transformation
on a given vector
is to scale that vector by some constant
we call it an
eigenvector of the transformation and we
call the relevant scaling factor the
corresponding eigenvalue
often denoted with the letter lambda
when you write this as an equation
and you rearrange a little bit
what you see is that if the number
lambda is an eigenvalue of a matrix
a then the matrix a minus lambda times
the identity
must send some non-zero vector namely
the corresponding eigenvector
to the zero vector which in turn means
that the determinant of this modified
matrix
must be zero okay that's all a little
bit of a mouthful to say but
again i'm assuming that all of this is
review for any of you watching
so the usual way to compute eigenvalues
how i used to do it and how i believe
most students are taught to carry it out
is to subtract the unknown value lambda
off the diagonals
and then solve for when the determinant
is equal to zero
doing this always involves a few extra
steps to expand out and simplify to get
a clean quadratic polynomial
what's known as the characteristic
polynomial of the matrix
the eigenvalues are the roots of this
polynomial so to find them
you have to apply the quadratic formula
which itself typically requires one or
two more steps of simplification
honestly the process isn't terrible but
at least for two by two matrices
there is a much more direct way that you
can get at the answer
and if you want to rediscover this trick
there's only three relevant facts that
you need to know
each of which is worth knowing in its
own right and can help you with other
problem solving
number one the trace of a matrix which
is the sum of these two diagonal entries
is equal to the sum of the eigenvalues
or
another way to phrase it more useful for
our purposes is that the mean of the two
eigenvalues
is the same as the mean of these two
diagonal entries
number two the determinant of a matrix
our usual a d minus bc formula
is equal to the product of the two
eigenvalues
and this should kind of make sense if
you understand that eigenvalues describe
how much an operator
stretches space in a particular
direction and that the determinant
describes how much an operator
scales areas or volumes as a whole
now before getting to the third fact
notice how you can essentially read
these first two values out of the matrix
without really writing much down
take this matrix here as an example
straightaway you can know that the mean
of the eigenvalues
is the same as the mean of 8 and 6 which
is 7.
likewise most linear algebra students
are pretty well practiced at finding the
determinant
which in this case works out to be 48
minus 8.
so right away you know that the product
of the two eigenvalues
is 40. now take a moment to see if you
can derive
what will be our third relevant fact
which is how you can quickly
recover two numbers when you know their
mean and you know their product
here let's focus on this example you
know that the two values are evenly
spaced around the number seven
so they look like seven plus or minus
something
let's call that something d for distance
you also know that the product of these
two numbers is 40.
now to find d notice that this product
expands really nicely
it works out as a difference of squares
so from there
you can directly find d d
squared is 7 squared minus 40 or 9 which
means that d
itself is 3.
in other words the two values for this
very specific example
work out to be 4 and 10. but our goal is
a quick trick
and you wouldn't want to think through
this each time so let's wrap up what we
just did in a general formula
for any mean m and product p
the distance squared is always going to
be m squared minus p
this gives the third key fact which is
that when two numbers have a mean
m and a product p you can write those
two numbers
as m plus or minus the square root of m
squared minus
p this is decently fast to rederive on
the fly if you ever forget it
and it's essentially just a rephrasing
of the difference of squares formula
but even still it's a fact that's worth
memorizing so it's at the tip of your
fingers
in fact my friend tim from the channel
acapella science wrote us a nice quick
jingle to make it a little bit more
memorable
[Music]
let me show you how this works say for
the matrix 3141
you start by bringing to mind the
formula maybe stating it all in your
head
[Music]
but when you write it down you fill in
the appropriate values for
m and p as you go so in this example the
mean of the eigenvalues
is the same as the mean of three and one
which is two
so the thing you start writing is two
plus or minus the square root of two
squared minus
then the product of the eigenvalues is
the determinant
which in this example is 3 times 1 minus
1 times 4
or negative 1 so that's the final thing
you fill in
which means the eigenvalues are 2 plus
or minus the square root of 5.
you might recognize that this is the
same matrix i was using at the beginning
but notice how much more directly we can
get at the answer
here try another one this time the mean
of the eigenvalues is the same as the
mean of 2 and
8 which is 5. so again you start writing
out the formula
but this time writing 5 in place of m
[Music]
and then the determinant is 2 times 8
minus 7 times 1
or 9 so in this example
the eigenvalues look like 5 plus or
minus the square root of 16
which simplifies even further as 9 and
1.
you see what i mean about how you can
basically just start writing down the
eigenvalues while you're staring at the
matrix
it's typically just the tiniest bit of
simplification at the end
honestly i've found myself using this
trick a lot when i'm sketching quick
notes related to linear algebra and want
to use small matrices as examples
i've been working on a video about
matrix exponents where eigenvalues pop
up a lot
and i realize it's just very handy if
students can read out the eigenvalues
from small examples
without losing the main line of thought
by getting bogged down in a different
calculation
as another fun example take a look at
this set of three different matrices
which comes up a lot in quantum
mechanics they're known as the pauli
spin matrices
if you know quantum mechanics you'll
know that the eigenvalues of matrices
are highly relevant to the physics that
they describe
and if you don't know quantum mechanics
let this just be a little glimpse of how
these computations are actually very
relevant to real applications
the mean of the diagonal entries in all
three cases is zero
so the mean of the eigenvalues in all of
these cases is zero which makes our
formula look especially simple
what about the products of the
eigenvalues the determinants of these
matrices
for the first one it's 0 minus 1 or
negative 1.
the second one also looks like 0 minus 1
but it takes a moment more to see
because of the complex numbers
and the final one looks like negative 1
minus 0.
so in all cases the eigenvalues simplify
to be plus and minus one
although in this case you really don't
need a formula to find two values if you
know that they're evenly spaced around
zero and their product is negative one
if you're curious in the context of
quantum mechanics these matrices
describe
observations you might make about a
particle's spin in the x y or z
direction
and the fact that their eigenvalues are
plus and minus one
corresponds with the idea that the
values for the spin that you would
observe
would be either entirely in one
direction or entirely in another
as opposed to something continuously
ranging in between
maybe you'd wonder how exactly this
works or why you would use two by two
matrices that have complex numbers to
describe
spin in three dimensions and those would
be fair questions just
outside the scope of what i want to talk
about here you know it's funny i wrote
this section because i wanted some case
where you have two by two matrices that
aren't just toy examples or homework
problems
ones where they actually come up in
practice and quantum mechanics is great
for that
but the thing is after i made it i
realized that the whole example kind of
undercuts the point that i'm trying to
make for these specific matrices
when you use the traditional method the
one with characteristic polynomials
it's essentially just as fast it might
actually be faster
i mean take a look at the first one the
relevant determinant directly gives you
a characteristic polynomial of lambda
squared minus one
and clearly that has roots of plus and
minus one
same answer when you do the second
matrix lambda squared minus one
and as for the last matrix forget about
doing any computations traditional or
otherwise
it's already a diagonal matrix so those
diagonal entries
are the eigenvalues however
the example is not totally lost to our
cause where you will actually feel the
speed up
is in the more general case where you
take a linear combination of these three
matrices
and then try to compute the eigenvalues
you might write this as
a times the first one plus b times the
second
plus c times the third in quantum
mechanics this would describe spin
observations
in a general direction of a vector with
coordinates a b c
more specifically you should assume that
this vector is normalized
meaning a squared plus b squared plus c
squared is equal to one
when you look at this new matrix it's
immediate to see that the mean of the
eigenvalues
is still zero and you might also enjoy
pausing for a brief moment to confirm
that the product of those eigenvalues
is still negative one
and then from there concluding what the
eigenvalues must be
and this time the characteristic
polynomial approach would be by
comparison a lot more cumbersome
definitely harder to do in your head
to be clear using the mean product
formula is not fundamentally different
from finding roots of the characteristic
polynomial
i mean it can't be they're solving the
same problem one way to think about this
actually is that the mean product
formula is a nice way to solve
quadratics in general
and some viewers of the channel may
recognize this
think about it when you're trying to
find the roots of a quadratic given the
coefficients
that's another situation where you know
the sum of two values
and you also know their product but
you're trying to recover the original
two values
specifically if the polynomial is
normalized so that this leading
coefficient is one
then the mean of the roots will be
negative one-half times this linear
coefficient which is negative one times
the sum of those roots
for the example on the screen that makes
the mean five
and the product of the roots is even
easier it's just the constant term no
adjustments needed
so from there you would apply the mean
product formula and that gives you the
roots
[Music]
and on the one hand you could think of
this as a lighter weight version
of the traditional quadratic formula but
the real advantage is not just that it's
fewer symbols to memorize
it's that each one of them carries more
meaning with it i mean
the whole point of this eigenvalue trick
is that because you can read out the
mean and product
directly from looking at the matrix you
don't need to go through the
intermediate step of setting up the
characteristic polynomial
you can jump straight to writing down
the roots without ever explicitly
thinking about what the polynomial looks
like
but to do that we need a version of the
quadratic formula
where the terms carry some kind of
meaning
i realize this is a very specific trick
for a very specific audience
but it's something i wish i knew in
college so if you happen to know any
students who might benefit from this
consider sharing it with them the hope
is that it's not just one more thing
that you memorize
but that the framing reinforces some
other nice facts that are worth knowing
like how the trace and the determinant
are related to eigenvalues
if you want to prove those facts by the
way take a moment to expand out the
characteristic polynomial for a general
matrix
and then think hard about the meaning of
each of these coefficients
many thanks to tim for ensuring that
this mean product formula will stay
stuck in all of our heads for at least a
few months
[Music]
if you don't know about acapella science
please do check it out
the molecular shape of you in particular
is one of the greatest things on the
internet
[Music]
you